What we miss is that technology doesn't destroy jobs. Technology democratises
work by destroying skills.
But I think there's a misconception in the press and in the headlines at the moment
about the headlines are job destruction. And the threat of technology destroying
jobs has been present since before the Luddites were destroying looms in the
Industrial Revolution.
It's been there for centuries. And if you take a macro view right here, right now,
here we are 200 years after the Luddites, there are more people in work today than
ever before.
And the unemployment rate across the developed world is broadly, it has picked up
in the last couple of months, but is broadly at multi-decade lows.
I am far, far, far from saying everything's perfect. It isn't.
But there's more people in work and we have multi-decade lows of unemployment.
It does specific things very, very well.
The example I use in the book is of naval shipyard workers wearing exoskeletons.
Anyone of my generation who remembers Aliens, the movie, the last scene in the
spaceship is where the hero, Ripley, is wearing the exoskeleton and there are servo
motors and whatever going.
Now, prior to wearing the exoskeleton, the work was characterised by having to lift
really heavy tools, hours on end, lugging them around.
You know, physically, totally demanding.
More sick days than the average worker.
So demanding that the quality of life was poor at best.
Go home from work, crash out on the couch.
Now wearing the tool, it's weightless.
You guide it rather than wielding it.
You can't drop it on your foot.
Quality of life immeasurably improved.
And two people are more productive than three people without.
Fine.
But notice what has happened.
Before the implementation of the exoskeleton, how would you get the job?
And for those of you on the video watching this, I suspect that neither I or your
good self would have got the job.
Probably not.
Because what did you need?
What characteristics, skill, behaviour, competence, whatever you want to call it,
would you need to get the job?
You'd need to be able to lift heavy weights, hours on end.
That's neither of us two.
No.
You'd need a gym bunny.
The strap line for the job advert would be, why not work out and get paid?
That kind of thing.
But now with an exoskeleton, anyone can do the job regardless of physical ability.
So the technology has democratised the work.
It has opened up talent pools the employer has never previously considered.
And it has removed the uniqueness in the individual who historically would have got
the job.
No longer need you to be fit and butch.
The dream is ours.
We can go and get jobs in naval shipyards now.
But that's the point.
It removes our uniqueness.
So ChatGPT, Copilot, Claude, whatever is your AI of choice, kind of dumbs down
doing things.
It will give us a presentation.
It will give us a marketing plan.
It will give us a finance plan.
And it will give us a starter for 10.
Still need some capability to know if it's any good.
Yeah.
Still need to have that intelligence, human intelligence, to parse the answer and
so forth.
But that's what technology does.
It democratises work by removing skills.
And that's the difference.
And broadly, and for brevity and time, the skills that they identify, the top 16
skills they identify fall into three buckets.
The first bucket is the skills around creativity, innovation, you know, seeing the
hidden meaning in things, visualisation, the storytellers, the people who can assimilate
the data, package it, and communicate to others and engage them, motivate them and
tell a compelling story to help us move directions and so forth.
And interestingly, in that context, you've seen in schooling, 15-year-old daughter
again, you've seen in schooling a shift from a focus on STEM.
And certainly, if you rewound five years, it was, get your kids into STEM, science,
technology, engineering, maths, STEM, STEM, STEM, STEM, coding, etc.
Coding is no longer a golden ticket.
AI is doing that very effectively.
And that STEM has shifted to STEAM.
And the A, the addition of the A is for art.
And again, fascinatingly, future of work, this is the rise of artist engineers.
This is turning the clock back 500 years to the original artist engineer, Leonardo
da Vinci.
So it's that visualisation, hidden meaning, what's going on, creativity, innovation.
That's one bucket.
Second bucket is what the WEF calls self-efficacy.
This is how we are.
How are we looking after ourselves?
How are we developing and growing?
How are we looking after our careers?
How resilient are we?
How are we learning?
An interesting challenge is if you consider how much money you spend on training
yourself, learning, developing in your lifetime, your 85-whatever years on planet
Earth, how much of that learning budget has been spent by the time you leave
university at the age of 23?
I would suggest it's probably 70, 80%.
So you've spent 70 to 80%, if not more, on your entire lifetime learning.
By the time you hit 24 and you've got 50 years in work.
That's an interesting discussion.
So how do you keep learning?
And the third bucket and the biggest bucket in the WEF report is leadership and
management skills.
And of all the skills they identified in that update, since the book was published,
those connected with leadership and management of others saw the biggest increase
in importance.
By 2030, the biggest skills gap between the demand of employers and supply will be
in technology.
Yeah, that's possibly not the biggest insight ever known to mankind.
The second biggest gap, and it is only marginally smaller, is people and leadership
skills.
And if you think, what's the single biggest line item on the vast majority of
organisations' P&Ls?
It's people costs.
It's people.
Whether it's direct or indirect, whether it's the offices to house them or the
salaries to pay for them or whatever it is.
It's people.
If I could raise the productivity of your people by just 1%, you would probably
thank me an awful lot.
And managers, leaders have a massive, massive impact on us.
The impact of our manager on an employee's mental health is the same as the impact
of your partner on your mental health.
So what are you thinking?
What do you think?
I don't think we spend enough time.
I think we're so busy.
But actually, what do you think?
And it goes back to this: I'm not worried about whether machines are thinking.
I'm worried about whether humans think.
Just what do you think?
And if you need time to work out what your opinion is, create the time.
Because otherwise, I just think we get bobbed along and carried on the flow and the
ebbs and so forth.